then Shapiro's the editor in chief of
the daily wire and host of the Vinci
Paris show and he joins us now to react
what's your reaction to all of that Ben
oh this is fun isn't it you watching
watching these people panic over Brett
Kavanaugh Brett Kavanaugh right we're
not talking about Amy Coneybear
we're not talking about even even
Catholic Cavanaugh is I think a very
solid stand up double not necessarily a
home run for the president to help a lot
better than Hillary Clinton hitting us
all in the head with a fastball but that
said the the level of panic that would
be evidenced by any Republican pick here
is so insane that it makes you believe
that the Democrats really don't care who
was nominated that this is really just
about Trump doesn't get his nominee of
course you will get his nominee and that
will make it even more delicious
obviously then you can't even make it up
that the women's March organization they
put out a press release last night that
basically here's what they said in
response to Donald Trump's nomination of
xx to the Supreme Court the women's
March released the following statement
Trump's announcement today is a death
sentence for thousands of women by the
way they spelled Brett Cavanaugh's name
wrong later in that release but the
opening of it was we oppose expects as
in yep anyone we will resist to take out
the xxxx and fill it in with his name my
favorite part of that though is that
thousands of people are going to die so
I mean I feel immoral this morning I've
not been killed by net neutrality I've
not been killed by tax cuts I've not
been killed by Brett Kavanaugh I
survived night one of the Cavanaugh
collapse I mean I don't know what about
the Paris Club yeah almost died from the
Paris climate of course but some but
survived that somehow so I mean either
I've been working out or the Democrats
are lying to me one of the two I think
both thank you well we also want to play
this clip now if you have kids at home
that are watching get him out of the
room because this is very offensive you
have the comedian michelle wolf who
spoke at the White House Correspondents
Dinner a few months back and she is
giving her own version of this patriotic
salute amid the media Supreme Court
hysteria by saying I didn't want to say
it I'm gonna let her say it listen to
this and then we'll get your reaction
[Applause]
yo the power to give life and then we'll
try to control that alright Ben your
reaction oh she's obviously a delight
you know the continual elevation of
comedians who have no interest in making
you laugh they only are interested in
making a clap right there they're gonna
get clapped er this is what's very
important is if people clap for them it
demonstrates the the full-scale leftism
of so many on the comedic left beyond
that the movement on the left from safe
legal and rare - god bless abortion go
get one hey that that is so morally
bereft it is so morally empty and insane
but it makes you think that a lot of
these folks have decided that abortion
is not something that ought to be
avoided if possible even if you believe
in it but that abortion is actually a
sacrament that it's a sign of bravery
that it's a sign of something good you
are a better person not only if you
support abortion but if you've had one
because you stood up to the patriarchy
well if you see this is nothing out of
an incipient human life as something
that is affirmative ly good I would say
that you are you are bordering on or in
the midst of a deep bout of evil then
where does that shift come from safe
legal and rail rare to celebration
how does that happen I think the
Democratic Party the studies show that
since 2010 they've moved radically to
the left and I think that they are so
resistant to the idea that the science
is now showing earlier and earlier how
much maybe looks like a baby in the womb
that they've decided it's important to
come out and actually champion sin as
opposed to suggesting that sin ought to
be legal and and again I think that it's
the original position I think was
unsustainable this is a more honest
position but it's also a much more evil
position in fact she went on to that
monologue and said quote some people say
abortion is killing a baby it's not it's
stopping a baby from happening well some
people say Michelle wolf is killing
comedy but she's actually just stopping
comedy from happening that's gonna have
to be the final word yes the file will
appear oh thank for your time in a great
podcast we appreciate it